this is what a sheriff's patrol looks
like in the age of coronavirus
in west hollywood deputies can now fine
anyone for not wearing a mask
do you have a mask yeah i said set the
shot so you don't
most need just a gentle reminder we're
not looking to ruin your day we're not
looking to ruin anybody's life we're not
looking to
find you into oblivion but we want to
garner your attention
and as most americans when a finest
being placed on them
they're more apt to follow the rules but
fines are the least of the financial
worries haunting these streets
with cases surging they're on the brink
of reimposing
stay-at-home orders it could devastate
an economy
barely recovering safety is of course of
number one priority but the shutdowns
are unacceptable
and they're unacceptable because it's
it's taking a sledgehammer
to a fly if you will it creates a toxic
environment for the business community
to where we're not going to have small
businesses west hollywood's the heart of
lgbtq los
angeles at his hardware store russ
wilson says the mood now reminds him of
the fear and uncertainty
of the hiv aids outbreak here he's
seeing
friends lose businesses too i've been
here 43 years
i know a lot of people in the community
and it's devastating to see them
going through what they're going through
this gelato shop had only been open six
months when the last stay-at-home order
came in march
now they pre-pack all the ice cream and
worry what's next
the thing that makes me more afraid is
that we don't know
if how and when you know so we just
opened the door and we don't know if we
will be able to run the business today
people that have been passing through
the second world war
they don't waste food they cannot leave
the light
uh open in a room because this make them
feel bad because they pass through those
uncertain times and the same i believe
will be for our generation
for the kids that are growing in these
times they're they will be
affected all their life about afraid of
germs
contamination uh don't go in too much
crap too
crowd places so i think we need all to
deal with this and
figure out how to make money and still
run business
they acted quickly here at the start of
the outbreak but reopening too fast has
come at a cost
that loss of lives and livelihoods is a
lesson for the world
greg milam sky news west hollywood